[Música]
só ao longo da minha vida profissional
eu convivi com vários educadores e
educadoras diretores de escola
profissionais do mundo social como um
todo mas sobretudo com muitos jovens
jovens com as suas angústias sociedades
e dialogando sobre educação e eu queria
apresentar para vocês
o felipe que é um estudante de nova
olinda interior do ceará passar por
favor como meus pais não foram bem
sucedidos na vida deles também não me
influenciavam não me dava força para
estudar
[Música]
achavam que quem entrava na universidade
era filho de rico
acho que eles não acreditavam que um
pobre também pudesse ter conhecimento
que pudesse ser inteligente sabe
para eles o máximo para terminar o
ensino médio e armao emprego trabalhar
na roça tipo
o vendedor ou alguma coisa do tipo
acho que nunca me sonharam sendo
um psicólogo nunca me sonharam sendo um
professor
nunca me sonharam sendo um médico
eles não foi a vão me ensinaram a sonhar
eu aprender e sonhar fazem estou
aprendendo a viver também praticamente
só
[Música]
nunca sonharam felipe e essa é uma
história comum no brasil como um todo
não só no interior do ceará
em última instância é expressão não só
dos pais de felipe evidentemente
conhecia a mãe do felipe depois uma
carinho enorme por ele mas de uma
sociedade que talvez pense pouco o seu
futuro
temos aqui um austríaco que vem o brasil
pós primeira guerra fugiu da guerra um
grande escritor adorou o brasil criou
essa expressão contida no seu livro o
brasil do futuro que infelizmente a
gente reconhece que é um eterno vir a
ser os países não conseguiu projetar o
seu futuro está o tempo todo titubeando
dentro dessa agenda pra saber ao longo
do tempo qual efetivamente é o seu
futuro
acho que ele está discutindo aqui é o
poder da educação como transformadora de
uma sociedade que precisa se projetar
com radicalidade para dar conta dos
desafios que o mundo contemporâneo está
trazendo gente pensar rápido dentro de
cada um de vocês quantos nomes de
membros de juízes do supremo tribunal
federal cada um conhece depois peço
àqueles que têm filhos enquanto os nomes
dos professores os filhos de vocês
sobretudo o ensino médio são 31 14 vocês
conhecem
nós conhecemos então é agenda toda de
projetar esse futuro tanto passa por
várias dimensões do campo educacional
nós fizemos avance o primeiro muito
importante primeiro campo importante é
que a gente avançou muito muito muito
com a constituição cidadã de 1988
nós fizemos avanços que estão listados
aí um quinto da população adulta é
analfabeta hoje caiu para 21% um texto
os brasileiros de 14 4 a 17 anos estão
fora da escola agora só 5% um quarto das
crianças chegavam aos 10 anos de idade
sem ler e escrever
e agora esse número caiu para 3% no
entanto apesar dos enormes avanços mas
continuamos com muitas limitações no
campo da educação
de cada 100 meninas e meninos que entra
no cação só 65 ensino médio a gente tem
uma situação em que 35% das crianças que
viram os jovens nós já abrimos mão deles
e eles saem da escola
muitos deles como está dito aí não chega
o ensino médio
daqueles que chegam muitos vão embora
eles são invadidos a escola expulsa
daqueles que ficam alguns aprendem
aquilo que aprendem não sabemos muito
bem o sentido que se dá só para ter essa
classificação aqui uma classificação do
inep e do mec
níveis abaixo do básico e básico não são
níveis desejáveis serem desejados
adequado e avançado vamos ver o que
acontece em matemática no brasil 70% dos
jovens está abaixo do básico 27% no
básico e seria desejado que todo mundo
estivesse acima do avançado só pegar um
exercício
se vocês olharem pra ver simplesmente
exercício para fabricar 960 salgadinhos
duas cozinheiras trabalham juntas por
seis horas ao dia querem aumentar para
1.400 traz mais uma pessoa pergunta é
como é que eu faço isso para esse trio
alcançar essa meta em seis horas por dia
é uma simples regra de 3 70% dos jovens
brasileiros não são capazes de fazer
essa regra de três estudantes
brasileiros podem demorar mais de 260
anos para atingir a proficiência em
leitura dos países ditos ricos
em matemática a previsão é que os
brasileiros lembram 75 anos para atingir
a pontuação média registrada nesse país
o que nos interessa portanto aqui nessa
sociedade do conhecimento
a gente tá vendo que o brasil tem níveis
de aprendizagem muito abaixo do que são
necessários e além do mais por isso que
é muito perturbador a fronteira do
conhecimento avançando tocando cantando
conhecimentos na ciência na universidade
na posse universidade no doutorado foram
na educação básica
nessa sociedade conhecimento que está a
ser uma sociedade de massas em que todos
detenham para poder ser transformadores
produtivos e criativos inovadores e
felizes precisam de adensamento de
conhecimento nós estamos em níveis
baixos e vem da fronteira avançar numa
velocidade muito maior
a nossa dívida histórica se mantém alta
ea gente está se perdendo a capacidade
de chegar na fronteira
pronto a gente tem mega tendências nesse
mundo né mega tendências fundamentais
a minha tendência da globalização dos
mercados integrados do mundo segundo a
sociedade circulando todos os demais
associados à migração exceto as mudanças
demográficas a população ficando mais
velha fica mais velho produtiva
discutindo a quarta idade não mais a
terceira idade como é que as pessoas com
80 anos de idades serão produtivas
mas além disso a gente tem mudanças
climáticas vários dizem que não existe
mas evidentemente todo o corpo de
ciência desse mundo reconhece que nós
que estamos ameaçados do planeta
o atleta não deve acabar mas nós no
planeta se continuar crescendo do jeito
que vai se passar de 2 graus nós não
estaremos aqui última questão mais
importante toda associada mundo
tecnológico
vendam a idéia da automação da
inteligência artificial da quarta
revolução industrial ou seja uma
redefinição completa dos modos de
trabalho inclusive a grande maioria dos
empregos que atualmente existem deixaram
de existir um tempo no período muito
rápido ea capacidade da sociedade que de
conhecimento dar conta de nós temos uma
plasticidade na forma de aprender para
inserir-se nessas mega tendências
evidentemente isso está implicado uma
agenda em que a gente precisa entender
que é fundamental se vocês quiserem
primeiro nível de conhecimento
a idéia das disciplinas mas a idéia de
aprender matemática aprender a língua
portuguesa de química e física está
simplesmente um desses nove itens que
estão vendo nascer este como um todo
a empresa também a questão
interdisciplinar aquisição de
conhecimento prático a gente precisa sem
dúvida e habilidades cognitivas e metas
cognitivas de social e emocional
a gente precisa fidh habilidades físicas
e práticas e precisa de valores e
atitudes pessoais sociais globais para
dar conta de atitudes e competências que
levam a ações
essa sociedade do conhecimento precisa
radicalmente de forma distinta do que
foram
há poucos anos atrás do que há 40 anos
atrás ela precisa deste complexo de
competência para dar conta da sua
inserção
se um jovem numa escola tiver como um
desafio da conta de entender a realidade
local ele pode hoje com muita facilidade
em vários lugares do mundo desenvolva
um drone desenvolveu um drone a baixo
custo e sidrônio vai passar pela
comunidade vai identificar as áreas que
não estão habitadas vai ficar áreas de
risco é ver onde tem dengue vai
processar esses dados em geral a
documentação vai ter um gps vai retornar
para a comunidade vai conversar com seus
pais com seus avós com seus pares e
produzir soluções isso tudo associado a
conhecimentos que têm a ver com a
capacidade de produzir empatia de
entender o trabalho coletivo de tomar a
decisão de ter a análise crítica que são
movimentos vitais associados a idéia da
disciplina e da interdisciplinaridade e
aquilo que vem além mas ainda estão os
reféns do campo da disciplina uma
educação que lembre vital para o
crescimento econômico o economista
chamado hanushek da universidade de
tampa e estima mais ou menos que a gente
chegasse todo mundo nos níveis
baixíssimos qualidade que nós temos hoje
mas se todos os jovens e as crianças
estivessem na escola brasileira e
aprendesse baixíssimo que a gente tem o
crescimento da economia seria quatro
pontos cinco a mais do que nós temos
hoje
se todos saírem daquele nível abaixo do
básico estivesse no básico
nós estamos crescendo um pib produto
interno bruto mais 10% ao ano
mais do que isso a gente sabe que está
associado para dar um dado para você já
da questão da violência
levantamento do ceará em 2015
os jovens que foram mortos nós sabemos
que nós temos um genocídio em curso para
a juventude brasileira como um todo
sobretudo entre a juventude negra da
periferia mas os jovens que morreram no
ceará
nesse levantamento 2015 60% deles tinham
abandonado a escola entre um dia e seis
meses antes de serem mortos não está na
escola hoje no brasil mata além de
pensar em sua agenda de desenvolvimento
humano que está associada à capacidade
nós estamos integrados à sociedade do
conhecimento que nos solicitam uma
riqueza uma dinâmica uma vida potencial
de transformação muito maior do que
tínhamos há pouco tempo atrás está
integralmente determinada e mergulhada
no campo dessa educação contemporânea
como avançar é só uma grande lista que
vocês vão ver uma visão de educação
básica fundamental que esteja preocupado
o desenvolvimento pleno integral das
crianças altas expectativas de
aprendizagem e nenhuma - um estudante a
menos em um abaixo desse nível básico um
currículo a idéia é alinhar expectativas
de aprendizagem que a gente tem que tá
caminhando nessa direção pode ser um
enorme avanço com múltiplas linguagens e
perspectivas os conhecimentos valores
atitudes associadas como contemporâneo
em autonomia dos estudantes para
aprender ao longo da vida aprender a
aprender mais do que isso a valorização
e formação dos professores
a idéia de que é preciso selecionar bem
os professores lembra que 87% das
matrículas do brasil são de escolas
públicas
mas a grande maioria dos professores
formados em escolas privadas
precisa ter capacidade de valorizar esse
professor atrair professor e dá conta
que eles aprendam técnicas de ensinar de
forma dedicada a dar bem aula aprender a
dar a aula que é necessário em cada
turma e não há aula que ele sabe da
primeira parte da conta de enfrentar os
desafios da sociedade do conhecimento
além disso nós temos dá conta de um
financiamento que seja redistributivo
que dê conta da infraestrutura que crie
condições de aprendizagem se você
atravessarem o brasil vocês vão ver o
que é trabalhar numa favela em que você
tem 31 texto do teu tempo de aula
fechadas por causa de tiroteios ou você
entrar na população ribeirinha no pará e
saber como é que você faz um
deslocamento de três horas para poder
chegar até a escola
você precisa dar conta e ter essa
relação e mais do que isso eles até de
gestão gestão aqui não é tecnologia a
cia na burocracia é um foco absoluto na
capacidade do serviço da escola está
todo orientado para que as crianças e os
jovens tenham condições de aprender e
aprender ao longo da vida é o focado no
resultado no resultado de aprendizagem
cognitiva sócio emocional e focado em
ter um ambiente em que a troca se dê a
favor da transformação e da mudança
agora isso não se dá só para alguns é
fundamental diz pensar que nesta
sociedade contemporânea nós precisamos
dar conta de políticas educacionais que
dêem sentido para esse futuro que
projeta um futuro com capacidade
transformadora mas que todos já estejam
quem é que cabe no todos e de cada um de
nós eu vou chamar pra vocês 16 segundos
sua fala de jamile uma estudante de
santarém no pará
é difícil de menor
ser mulher
ser negro e ser pobre é difícil
é difícil é difícil num país marcado
pela desigualdade marcado pelo racismo
marcado por várias formas de
discriminação ter uma escola que dê
conta de acolher a sua diversidade de
forma irônica a diversidade a nossa
maior força ea educação tem a maior
potência de transformação como é que a
gente faz isso e produzindo uma agenda
de excelência com equidade produto
organizando a educação por altas
expectativas e altas expectativas para
todos uma intencionalidade na política
pública que esteja a serviço do
conhecimento a serviço do
desenvolvimento humano e a serviço de
uma sociedade mais justa e mais
inclusiva é a educação que tem potência
de reposicionar nossa estratégia de
curto médio longo prazo nessa direção
lembre que um jovem hoje 18 anos que
está concluindo com esse grau de
aprendizagem precário será um adulto de
30 anos em 2030
uma criança que entrou hoje 6 anos na
escola terá 18 em 2030 e será um adulto
em 42 portanto como é que a gente vai
lidar com essa situação e aí pra
concluir eu queria citar uma frase do
dramaturgo nelson rodrigues muito
importantes o desenvolvimento não se
improvisa subdesenvolvimento é uma obra
de séculos
a questão chave é que desenvolvimento
também não se improvisa precisa de
evidências de ciência de coerência de
consistência não passa pelo achismo não
passa pela opinião que eu tenho acerca
da educação a um repertório enorme de
evidências no brasil e no mundo práticas
absorvente potente transformação que
devem informar o que a gente quer
colocar na agenda da educação para de
forma refletida dá conta da agenda
desenvolvimento mas o desenvolvimento
também não pode ser uma obra de séculos
isso seria absolutamente irresponsável
desenvolvimento é obra dessa geração pra
sonhar o nosso brasil para projetar o
nosso brasil para fazer um projeto
futuro que seja ousado e ambicioso
realista que dê conta de ser dinâmico
bahia dinâmico justo e equânime diverso
transformador aquilo que nesta sociedade
de conhecimento é mais necessário uma
educação refletida e dedicada à altas
expectativas para todos e garantindo que
esse desenvolvimento seja obra nossa
dessa geração
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]